I said we wouldn't always be working with square roots, sometimes we can work
with a cube root. When we take a cube root, we're really trying to find triples
of a factor that are underneath the radical sign. In other words, we need a
factor raised to the 3rd power underneath here in order to remove it from the
radical symbol since it's a cube root. We can think of cube roots as a side
length of cube with a given volume. For example, if this cube has a volume of
8, you want to find the side lengths that multiply together three times to give
us 8. So, what do you think are the side lengths for each of these cubes? Keep
in mind that the side lengths of a cube are equal, and the volume can be found
by multiplying the same number together three times.